SAL KHAN: This is Sal here.
And I'm at Stanford
Medical School
with Dr. Andy Connolly,
who's a pathologist here.
And this is the
second in our series
on looking at some
of these slides.
ANDY CONNOLLY: Yeah.
So we left off last time,
Sal, looking at this piece
here, which is normal colon.
We had said this is an
example of what you'd
see at the edge of a specimen
released for colon cancer.
Now I'm going to click
to the next one, which
is a slightly more
worrisome area if you're
a pathologist looking
through the colon.
And so I'm going to zoom
in just a little bit here
to take a look at these.
SAL KHAN: Looks very worrisome
compared to the last one.
ANDY CONNOLLY: And
so what we don't
like about it is
we saw before this
is what the normal
gland looks like.
It's a test tube
shape and down, and it
has these cells
which are normal.
Now all of a sudden it
looks a little thicker here,
and what catches our eye
also is these aren't just
straight test tubes anymore.
They divide.
They kind of go in
and out like that.
SAL KHAN: But they
still are test tubes.
Following up what we
said in the last video
is that they just look
like circles as opposed
to test tubes because we're
taking a cross-section,
because they're kind of popping
out of the two dimensions.
ANDY CONNOLLY: That's right.
But although, when you
come from the surface here
and you go down, they
normally should never branch.
SAL KHAN: I see.
ANDY CONNOLLY: And so
these ones are branching,
and that's always bad.
And then you can
see the way-- when
you're putting a
cross-section, there's
normally just a little
hole in the middle.
And that's where the
mucin-- you can even see it
spilling out there.
SAL KHAN: Wow.
You can.
ANDY CONNOLLY: So you
can see it just kind
of coming right out of there.
This one here looks different.
And what it is, it's piled up.
And so it's a little
bit bigger around.
And in order for these
cells, more cells--
they're going to be all
piled up and going like this,
and they even branch.
And so what this
is, is that we look
a little more closely
at this piece.
And we say, hmm, I
wonder if that's cancer.
Could it be pre-cancer,
or is this just
an area of irritation?
And a common response of
the body to irritation
is some sort of change.
And like we were saying before,
epithelium is the top layer.
SAL KHAN: Right, right.
The stuff that's facing
the outside world.
ANDY CONNOLLY: Facing
So if it's irritated, often
the epithelium will change.
And in this case, it's changing
by undergoing more growth.
SAL KHAN: Is it always--
even if it's non-cancerous,
is it going to be a higher
likelihood that it's
going to become
cancerous in the future?
ANDY CONNOLLY: A lot
of cancers, it appears,
in the body come from parts
of the body that are either
irritated or have some sort
of environmental challenges
that are constantly at them.
And part of that is because
there's a lot of cell division.
SAL KHAN: I see.
ANDY CONNOLLY: If you
keep dividing a cell,
you might have
errors in the DNA.
SAL KHAN: So that's why
skin cells, bowel cells--
ANDY CONNOLLY: That's right.
And even things like liver.
If you keep damaging
your liver, you
might have ongoing
things and liver cancer.
So when you're looking
here, the pathologist
would look at this area
and say, well, it's
a dividing gland that's kind
of thrown up in these areas.
But largely, they're
still making mucin
or they're this type here,
which looks like it's tall
and probably absorbing water.
SAL KHAN: I see.
So even within these
test tubes-- well,
they're not really test tubes.
But inside of these
vessels, there
are also still the
absorptive cells as well.
ANDY CONNOLLY: That's right.
So here, we would sign
this off as hyperplasia.
SAL KHAN: Hyperplasia.
So hyper, like too
much of something.
ANDY CONNOLLY: Yes.
SAL KHAN: And plasia?
ANDY CONNOLLY: Growth.
SAL KHAN: See.
ANDY CONNOLLY: And so
plasia just means growth.
And so hyperplasia
means too much growth.
But the important thing is if
you took away the irritant,
it wouldn't do this.
SAL KHAN: I see.
ANDY CONNOLLY: So
if you took away
whatever the irritant
is for the hyperplasia,
it would go back
to being normal.
SAL KHAN: I see.
I see.
And that's just
something we know.
ANDY CONNOLLY: That's right.
SAL KHAN: There's
some stimulus that
was causing these
cells to do that.
It might have been diet,
might have been some chemical.
It could have been just--
ANDY CONNOLLY: We're
never really sure
what, because so
much of it is things
that just float on through.
So it's really hard to know.
But, yeah, this is probably
too much growth in response
to an irritant.
SAL KHAN: So it's
possible that it just
happened to be when this section
of the colon was taken out.
If this was done
a day later maybe,
then maybe this might
have not been there?
ANDY CONNOLLY: Yeah, probably
take longer than that.
A couple weeks.
SAL KHAN: A couple
weeks, but it's--
ANDY CONNOLLY:
Because what happens
is that the cells
come from the bottom,
and they work their
way up towards the top.
And so eventually the
top would behave--
SAL KHAN: And so the way
the body works here--
and it's kind of like the
skin-- is this as constant.
These cells are being
used up, because things
are kind of scraping by them.
And they get a lot of use.
ANDY CONNOLLY: They do.
And in fact, there's a lot
known now about stem cells.
And the stem cells for the
intestine are these guys.
SAL KHAN: Oh, wow.
So how do you differentiate
the stem cell versus--
ANDY CONNOLLY: At the very
bottom, the bottom hemisphere,
there are going
to be cells there
that do not have
the open chromatin
and kind of elongated.
SAL KHAN: I see.
ANDY CONNOLLY: There
may be ones which
are endocrine cells, meaning
they release hormones.
And so they may have
hormone-releasing cells.
But in this bottom
hemisphere, that
turns out to be where
the intestine keeps them.
And these guys are
probably the stem cells.
SAL KHAN: And stem
cells are cells
that haven't picked
their jobs yet.
ANDY CONNOLLY: They
haven't, and so there's
all kinds of stem cells.
There's the stem cell that
can make a whole body, being.
But then there's
also the kind that
can make the rest of the colon.
SAL KHAN: I see.
ANDY CONNOLLY: And so
this one is probably
the stem cell they can make
the rest of the epithelium,
but these two different kinds.
SAL KHAN: The two
different types, right.
ANDY CONNOLLY: So they're
down here at the bottom.
That's about where
you'd want them.
SAL KHAN: Exactly.
Right.
ANDY CONNOLLY: So
that makes sense.
So down there are your stem
cells, and it grows like that.
So this is a hyperplasia.
So I'd like to show you
next the next step, which
is a pre-cancer legion.
Should we do that
in another videos?
SAL KHAN: Yeah.
Let's do that in another video.